[Musique]
autrement dit ceux qui reçoivent sont
plus nombreux que ceux qui donnent et le
phénomène va s'amplifier encore d'ici 15
ans le nombre des vieux va s'accroître
de plus d'un million alors que celui des
adultes augmentera peu alors quelle
solution trouvée pour que cette
population inactive puissent vivre
décemment sens qu'elle constitue une
charge écrasante pour le pays et d'autre
part pour que les vieux continuent
d'être des consommateurs contribuant
ainsi à la nécessaire expansion
économique faut-il repousser l'âge de la
retraite une telle solution est elle
souhaitable possible humaine à cette
question une première objection
en sommes qu à travailler comme moi par
exemple je sais quoi encore ça fait
cinquante deux ans des taux ou le rendez
compte que tout le monde j'aurais tout
droit à un peu de repos comme justement
la vie mérite d'être vécue il ya quand
même il faut quand même
donner à l'individu une certaine large
quand même de deauville et dans toutes
les professions c'est pareil chez les
manuels comme chez les intellectuels
cette retraite vous l'avez prise avec
plaisir ou est ce que nous avons bien
sûr j'ai peut-être mêmes prises avec
anticipation c'est la donne à 65 ans a
fait trop bien tout le monde à are il
pas profité de leur père la frette pour
les hommes à 60 ans et pour les femmes
50 ans à 60 65 ans maximum
la
deuxième objection reculer l'âge de la
retraite c'est faire apparaître le
spectre du chômage pour les jeunes
il faut leur laisser la place qu'à pas
tout jeune qui revient du régiment qui
n'a pas de travail eh ben il trouvera
est la place des autres
j'estime que quand vous rentrez dans une
dans une société et tous les postes des
cadres sont mais même des chefs de
service sont occupés
c'est pénible pour vous de vous dire ah
ben il faudra attendre 10-15 ans avant
de pouvoir seulement avoir une belle
situation on a fait notre père et ils
demandent pas bien les jeunes que de le
faire on leur laisse la place au musée
d'aquio
d'ailleurs le rapport laroque ne demande
pas un recul de l'âge de la retraite ils
demandent le droit au travail pour ceux
qui le désirent mais les principaux
intéressés le souhaitent ils
tous évidemment ne sont pas du même avis
alors que je préparais travailler encore
parce que me semble que sans activité la
vie n'est pas très bien pour moi parce
qu'il est préférable de travailler un
peu plus longtemps quand l'on peut si on
a les moyens physiques de le faire si
vous aviez pu continuer à travailler ce
que vous auriez préféré est bien naturel
à moi ma femme a liquidé à quoi
voulez gagner trouver ensuite
tout si toulouse est passé 45
de trop vieux mais vous préféreriez
rabat bien sûr d'avoir au sens propre -
et puis
ça va mieux quand on vend
on s'emporte il faudrait trouver des
emplois à mi-temps pour ces gens qui
prennent leur retraite à 65 ans la
retraite guy yotine telle qu'on la
conçoit c'est à dire le passage brusque
la pleine activité à la plaine
inactivité est très peu recommandable à
la fois sur le plan physiologique
psychologique et aussi sur le plan
économique parce que il elle ne permet
pas de donner aux individus de quoi
vivre
et bien la solution c'est peut-être ces
images qu'ils l'apportent la solution
c'est peut-être ceci crée comme l'ont
fait deux ou trois entreprises de la
région parisienne créer des ateliers
spécialisés de travail du doubs qui
permettrait aux vieux travailleurs
d'atteindre l'âge de la retraite et même
s'ils en manifestent le désir de le
dépasser si les vieux pouvait continuer
à travailler dans ses ateliers après
leur retraite ils cesseraient d'être
exclu de la vie économique assurée
partiellement leurs besoins et n'aurait
plus le sentiment pénible d'être des
citoyens diminué comme le souligne le
professeur baulieu
donc ce qu'il faut simplement pour
essayer de maintenir les gens le plus
longtemps possible dans un état de santé
physique et mentale le meilleur possible
c'est de leur laisser le droit d'avoir
des occupations adaptés à leur âge
adapter leurs possibilités personnel qui
leur permettent non seulement augmenter
leurs ressources mais également d'avoir
au point de vue intellectuel au point du
physique de garder une certaine un
certain équilibre qui est nécessaire à
leur bien-être trop souvent il faut bien
se le dire et nous pouvons regarder dans
le fond même de notre conscience la
retraite est conçu comme un moyen de
faire partir les vieux d'une façon qui
débarrasse la population active qu'il
donne des emplois et on va même
quelquefois jusqu'à préconiser une sorte
de ségrégation dans des quartiers de
vieux pour qu'on ne les ai plus devant
les yeux pour qu'on soit débarrassé de
cette sorte de remords permanent vous
êtes prisonniers si l'ombre
il sort tous les jours alors mon exposé
à nier
les jeux on à la sortie et vieux
en
avril 2003
cette pauvre liberté cette misère en
images voilà le drame de la vieillesse
un problème économique peut-être mais
surtout une cruellement humain un drame
qui nous concerne tout ce dont nous
sommes tous solidaires oui ce problème
nous donne mauvaise conscience et nous
préférons l'escamoter si la solution
n'en apparaît peut-être pas encore
clairement il n'en demeure pas moins
posé devant le pays et personne n'a plus
le droit de s'en tirer par une pirouette
comme celui là qui sera vieux un jour
vieux
n'ont jamais pas y compter j'ai bien
pensé du tout
[Musique]